eso
[Música]
eres hombre o mujer
la primera vez que escuché esta pregunta
tenía 11 años estaba jugando fútbol en
el patio del recreo de mi colegio y un
chico al que no conocía se paró frente a
mí y me dijo eres hombre o mujer
yo no supe que responderle le tiré una
cachetada y él se fue
sentí muchísima vergüenza pero también
mucha rabia con el tiempo entendí que la
rabia que sentí no era rabia por que no
sabía si era hombre o mujer
él era rabia porque yo no sabía
responder a esa pregunta era rabia
porque por primera vez me enfrentaba a
una bifurcación que parecía no tener un
camino correcto para mí a los 11 años me
enfrenté por primera vez a una pregunta
que no tenía idea me iba a acompañar el
resto de mi vida
muchas veces las personas trans tenemos
que salir del closet no una sino dos
veces la primera vez que salí del closet
tenía 15 años y fue para decirle a mis
amigas del colegio que era lesbiana no
fue difícil para mí reconocerme como
lesbiana era muy obvio que me gustaban
las chicas desde siempre mi primera
novia la tuve a los 15 años y aunque
suene paradójico nos conocimos en una
comunidad religiosa
los guías espirituales de la comunidad
se enteraron
citaron a mi madre a mis espaldas y le
contaron todo me sacaron del closet y
destruyeron el vínculo de confianza con
mi madre un vínculo que nos tomó años
reparar
yo intenté ser heterosexual por amor a
dios y por miedo a ir al infierno por
mis pecados terminé con mi novia fui a
misas de sanación iba a la iglesia todos
los días
rezaba a toda hora intenté con todas mis
fuerzas dejar de ser lesbiana pero no
funciona así no es una etapa ni una
opción
la segunda salida del closet fue ya no
para aceptar mi orientación sexual sino
para asumir me como una persona trans la
segunda salida del closet fue la más
difícil para mí porque no tenía ninguna
información sobre lo trans ningún modelo
al que seguir y mucho menos una persona
que yo conociera que habiendo nacido
mujer como yo se identificara como trans
no habían smartphones ni había internet
en la casa ni había la cantidad de
vídeos en youtube cuentas de instagram o
grupos virtuales que hay hoy gracias al
trabajo de muchos activistas trans que
son recursos vitales para nuestra
supervivencia
la segunda salida del closet fue la más
difícil pues ya no se trataba de quienes
me atraían sino que se trataba de mi
propia identidad
por supuesto que nuestra orientación
sexual es una parte vital de quiénes
somos pero una crisis por tu identidad
de género se trata única y
exclusivamente de confrontar t cara a
cara contigo mismo aquí es cuando se
pone medio confuso en orientación
identidad sexo género vamos a explicarlo
un poquito una cosa es mi orientación
sexual esto es quienes me atraen con
quién es mi vínculo afectiva o
sexualmente a quienes amo mi orientación
sexual y otra cosa es mi identidad de
género cómo me reconozco cómo me
identifico quién soy en la soledad
absoluta de mi ser son dos esferas
distintas de nuestra humanidad
para mí descubrir mi identidad de género
empezó en medio de un escenario hace
cinco años forme parte de una obra de
teatro testimonial llamada desde afuera
en ella contaba mi conflicto con la
iglesia católica pero también mis
primeras experiencias de travestismo
también a los 15 años me ven daba el
pecho para aplanar mis tetas me ponía
boxers y medias entre las piernas
amarraba mi cabello entonces largo y lo
cubría con un gorro usaba la ropa de mi
hermano durante los dos años que duró
desde afuera
fui repitiendo esta escena una y otra
vez y en un momento empecé a sentirme
más feliz en mi versión travestida y
menos como de en mi versión normal de
mujer
y así empezó mi transición
iniciar mi transición no fue fácil
la transición suele ser un proceso en el
que dejas una identidad para ir en
búsqueda de una nueva o asumir una nueva
identidad y este puede ser un proceso
sumamente complejo y doloroso
yo pasé los meses de depresión más
severos de mi vida durante esta etapa y
tuve que empezar a trabajar con una
terapeuta para lidiar con mis impulsos
suicidas
nunca he hablado de esto abiertamente
pero es importante hacerlo de cada 10
personas trans entre 3 y 5 tenemos
intentos de suicidio y este número puede
subir a 5 de cada 10 si hablamos de
población trans adolescente
la depresión es aplastante decenas de
preguntas empiezan a aparecer en tu
cabeza alguna vez me voy a sentir cómodo
con mi cuerpo voy a necesitar cirugía o
tratamiento hormonal cómo voy a pagar
las operaciones que va a decir mi
familia que va a opinar mi mamá cómo se
van a sentir mis amigas que va a decir
mi pareja podré tener una pareja alguien
me va a querer así como me voy a llamar
voy a poder cambiar mi nombre podré
conservar mi trabajo tendré
oportunidades laborales voy a ser feliz
pero estás evidentemente no son las
únicas preguntas que aparecen en la
gente en la calle por supuesto también
parece estar muy confundida
a mí por ejemplo me han dicho en la
calle literalmente joven señorita señor
ay no sé pues que eres ya
y por más gracioso que esto me parezca
ahora en esa época me generaba ataques
de pánico y ansiedad y me podía pasar
días encerrada en mi cuarto otra vez la
maldita pregunta eres hombre o mujer
eres hombre o mujer crecemos en una
sociedad en la que solo existen estas
dos opciones o te identificas como
hombre o te identificas como mujer el
binario de género incluso para las
personas trans hombre trans mujer trans
es muy desesperante esa idea
pero la lógica me decía que si no me
sentía convencida o cómoda en la
etiqueta mujer entonces tenía que ser
hombre así que al iniciar mi transición
me identifique como un hombre trans sin
embargo nadie en la calle me percibía
como hombre por obvias razones y esto
generaba que mi ansiedad se disparara al
techo
la ansiedad la tristeza y la profunda
desesperanza que experimentamos algunas
personas trans por ese desfase entre
nuestra identidad y las expectativas que
tenemos de cómo se deberían ver nuestros
cuerpos se conoce como disforia una
palabra que me cambió la vida
la disforia es real y es abrumadora se
desata con cualquier comentario inocente
sobre ti que te recuerde este desfase
entre tu identidad y tu cuerpo
alguien diciéndote ella cuando te
reconoces como el alguien usando tu
antiguo nombre alguien en la calle
observando fijamente una parte de ti que
quisieras con todo tu corazón poder
desaparecer tu propio reflejo en el
espejo antes de tomar una ducha
así que el siguiente paso lógico es
hacerte cargo de este problema para que
te deje de arruinar la vida para mí una
solución aparente era la testosterona
y que no inconveniente es que soy
cantante y la testosterona modifica tus
cuerdas vocales al punto de alterar tu
voz sin control alguno someterme al tan
deseado tratamiento hormonal significaba
renunciar a años de trabajo con mi voz y
por otro lado renunciar a la
testosterona significaba renunciar a la
posibilidad de vivir mi vida plenamente
con el tiempo fui haciendo las paces con
la idea de no hacer testosterona pero no
solamente por mi voz sino porque fui
entendiendo que las categorías hombre u
hombre trans tampoco me sentaban bien no
me representaban
no quería verme como un hombre fui
entendiendo que hay otras opciones más
allá del binario de género
fui entendiendo que para mí el problema
no era encontrar una respuesta a la
pregunta eres hombre o mujer sino que
para mí el problema era la pregunta en
sí misma
solía pensar como muchas personas que la
transición es pasar de ave de una
identidad a otra que es polar mente
opuesta
como si pasáramos de un lado de la
moneda al otro como si sólo existieran
dos opciones en el menú de la humanidad
de ahí viene esta idea de el alma en el
cuerpo equivocado alguna vez han
escuchado esta expresión de un hombre
atrapado en el cuerpo de una mujer o
viceversa
si bien esta idea sirvió y sigue
sirviendo para que muchas personas trans
tengan acceso a tratamientos hormonales
y cirugías en los sistemas de salud
esta idea limita a nuestras experiencias
y nuestras vivencias al plano corporal y
médico es una idea que además deja de
lado las muchas formas de transición ar
que hay en nuestra comunidad no todos
nos identificamos dentro de ese binario
no todos queremos una transición binaria
no todos queremos siquiera modificar
nuestro cuerpo y eso también está bien
necesitamos dejar la idea de que todas
las transiciones son pasar de un punto a
a un punto b en el que vive sólo pueden
ser hombre o mujer el espectro trans es
tan infinito como personas trans
existimos en el mundo y es realmente
nocivo para nosotros vivir en un mundo
que sigue pensando que somos productos
fallidos no soy un alma puesta en un
cuerpo equivocado soy un ser con alma y
cuerpo en un mundo equivocado mi
experiencia como ser humano no debería
estar limitada por la efe en mi
documento de identidad o por los
genitales que llevo entre las piernas
ahora cuando la gente no sabe bien quién
o que soy me gusta
me encanta generar dudas y
cuestionamientos con mi sola presencia
entrar en un espacio y que la gente
entre en crisis y no sepa a joven hombre
o mujer
me gusta que mi cuerpo sea una
herramienta para cuestionar el binario
de género como única posibilidad por
favor dejemos esta idea de que solamente
somos a un hombre o mujer hacerlo es un
gran acto de amor hacia la diversidad de
personas trans que existimos pero por
favor no vayan a pensar que esto es un
invento mío un invento del siglo 21 la
ideología del género la degeneración de
la juventud o el instagram
durante los últimos años el trabajo de
muchas activistas artistas y colectivas
como no tengo miedo
javi vargas con su exposición en su kit
chinchay giuseppe campusano con el museo
travesti del perú nos han dejado
elecciones valiosísimas para entender
que existíamos las diversidades y las
disidencias trans en esta tierra mucho
antes de la colonización y que la
llegada europea vino a imponernos entre
otras cosas conceptos rígidos del género
que no existían antes en el libro la
descolonización del sodomita en los
andes' coloniales
el autor desenvuelva el mito de la
chucky chinchay o felino danzante presta
atención porque esto no te lo contaron
en el colegio la chucky chinchay era la
deidad o el apu protector de los
otorongos y los indios dos natural los
indios los natural o hari warmis eran de
acuerdo a la cosmovisión andina este
encuentro sagrado esta complementariedad
sagrada entre lo femenino y lo masculino
jari de el quechua hombre y warm y del
que he hecho a mujer hardware mí
cuenta la leyenda que el inca pachacútec
al llegar al cusco encuentra a su padre
al borde de la muerte y a su hijo a
punto de nacer invoca a sus chamanes
entre ellos al askari warmi y les pide
que invoquen a la appo djukic insight
este mito nos permite entender cuán
importantes eran estos seres en la
cosmovisión andina y en el orden social
sin embargo con la llegada de los
españoles empiezan las campañas de
extirpación de idolatrías y empiezan a
perseguir a la hardware missy a prohibir
todos los rituales andinos incluso en el
archivo general de las indias de 1.566
se prohíbe explícitamente la presencia
de seres femeninos masculinos en el
ámbito público
la realidad es que siempre hemos
existido en la india están las sierras
en méxico están las mucho en las
culturas nativas norteamericanas están
los indios dos natural siempre estuvimos
ahí nos han querido borrar de la
historia oficial pero aquí seguimos y
antes la pasábamos bastante mejor no nos
violentaban no nos perseguían y éramos
íntimas con la hinca para mí
identificarme como hardware mí no es
solamente reivindicar mi identidad trans
fuera del binario hombre-mujer para mí
identificarme como hardware me es
también reconocer y reivindicar mi
identidad andina es reconocer que somos
parte de la historia de este país y que
ser quien soy esa complementariedad
entre lo femenino y lo masculino no me
hace ni menos trans ni menos peruana ni
menos humana
guau
las hardware mis las muchas las las
series 2 naturas existimos desde siempre
y seguimos existiendo estamos aquí con
esto por favor quiero ser muy claro nada
de lo que estoy diciendo pretende
invalidar la diversidad de identidades
trans que existen y otras formas de
identificarse las mujeres trans o los
hombres trans las trans masculinidad es
las transferida des son tan válidas
legítimas maravillosas y bellas
identidades como las identidades trans
no hubieran no binarias nuestras luchas
son igual de importantes y válidas qué
pasaría si vivimos en un mundo en el que
todos tenemos la libertad de
identificarnos como queremos dónde está
la tragedia en pensar un país en el que
todas todos y todas tenemos la
posibilidad de elegir nuestras
identidades y vivirlas plenamente que
hubiera pasado conmigo si no me tomaba
20 años intentando ser mujer de una
forma que jamás me hizo feliz qué
hubiera pasado si me enseñaban en el
colegio sobre las hardware me y sobre el
astur y chincha y si entendía que mi
género es un universo que me compete
únicamente explorar
a mí qué pasaría con los niños y
adolescentes y crecen con las puertas
del mundo abiertas para explorar se para
descubrirse para auto determinarse
cuántas heridas incurables
desaparecerían cuántas muertes por
suicidio evitaríamos
dónde está la tragedia en pensar en
mundo así
cuando empecé mi transición conocía a
muy pocas personas como yo sin embargo
ahora mi vida está rodeada de personas
trans maravillosas ellas son mi
inspiración y mi fortaleza
una de ellas malú machuca cuando
estábamos en desde afuera le pregunto a
uno de nuestros directores cuántas
personas trans hay en tu vida
esta pregunta quedó para siempre grabada
en mi cuántas personas trans hay en tu
vida cuántas personas trans hay en tu
trabajo en tu familia en tu grupo de
amigos si la respuesta es pocas
preguntémonos porque ciertamente no es
porque no existimos o porque somos pocas
las personas trans estamos al final de
las siglas lgtb y no por coincidencia el
estado no nos reconoce no tenemos
documentos de identidad que reconozcan
nuestra existencia ni somos consideradas
en los censos
cuántas personas trans hay en tu vida si
la respuesta es pocas o ninguno hagamos
este ejercicio para darnos cuenta de
cuán marginalizadas estamos las personas
trans en este país y de cuán poco acceso
tenemos a las mismas oportunidades que
las personas no trans
por supuesto que no todas las personas
trans estamos en la misma situación de
violencia o marginalización yo soy una
persona trans muy privilegiada tengo la
piel clara vengo de una familia de clase
media fui a un colegio privado a una
universidad privada me dedico a ser
cantante y estoy dando una charla tetex
esta no es la realidad de la mayor parte
de personas trans ni en el perú ni en el
mundo
y hay otras formas de discriminación que
hacen que estas experiencias de
violencia sean mucho más severas
nuestras compañeras trans en situación
de precarización nuestras compañeras
trans afro indígenas viviendo con vih
tienen realidades mucho más complejas y
urgentes que la mía pero no estoy aquí
para hablar por nadie y mucho menos para
hablar por todos pero tengo la
oportunidad de usar el privilegio de
estar en este escenario esta noche para
recordarles que existimos que siempre
hemos existido y que seguimos muriendo
de indiferencia
la esperanza de vida para las personas
trans es entre 35 y 40 años el año
pasado una adolescente trans de 14 años
fue asesinada en trujillo su ley me y
nadie parece recordarla
según conocida vivimos en la región más
homofóbica y transfóbica del mundo el 80
por ciento de homicidios a personas
trans sucede en américa latina' es
imposible no verlo marginadas y
excluidas que estamos pero que estamos
haciendo para cambiarlo cuántas personas
trans hay en tu vida a cuántas personas
trans ves en la calle a cuántas personas
trans te cruzas en los colegios en el
banco en los negocios a cuántas personas
trans has contratado para trabajar
contigo de cuántas personas trans te has
enamorado o siquiera permitido pensar en
la posibilidad de fijarte en una de
ellas donde están las personas trans en
nuestro país donde están las hardware
mis de nuestra historia cuántas personas
trans hay en tu vida
gracias
[Aplausos]